reject nation gravity falls continues
here on the channel take the
hit that like button if you can also
please subscribe click that notification
bell to get notified when our reactions
when the next gravity falls is up here
on the page big thanks to the boys who
are prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights and also major thanks
to all who have joined our patreon page
and become superior jacks by checking
out everything we got to offer over
there as well full-length washer logs
gravity falls is that's where you'll
catch them anyway guys let's get to it
i think the sky tram is broken
also most of my bones
this guy all right all
right poor guy
bunch of fake safety inspection
certificates go slap one on anything
that looks like a lawsuit grunkle stan
is that legal when there's no cops
around anything's legal so true
almost ready to go mr pines don't call
the grunkle
hey you haven't seen my red screwdriver
have you darned thing went missing maybe
some magical creature or paranormal
thingham took it hey you've been
spending too much time with those kids
not around here
the mission is proceeding as planned
over
ooh
camo suit
and a justin royland voice over how do
they get them into this shape it's
unnatural but dipper they're so
delicious
[Laughter]
bonding over punctuations
hey yeah i got some new super tight
jeans thought she might want to check
them out
gross
don't worry brother whatever happens
i'll be right here supporting you every
step of the oh my gosh oh pigs
win a pig mabel how could you sir i must
have that pig
ah oh 15 poundy
[Laughter]
spot on mabel
here's your pig
whoa check it out
i don't know if it's a duck or a panda
but i want one it's a pan duck you aim
for the carny's head and take the prize
when he's unconscious
nice
one ball please you only get one chance
lose yourself and a two and
whoa
oh
does it look swollen
everything's gonna be fine don't worry
i'll i'll go get some ice punch her
other eye
symmetry
she where is she
no
hey watch where you're going man
oh
you wanted to go out with me uh yeah i
guess so
look dipper i won my pet big his name is
waddle i need one
[Music]
funnel of love and corn dog tunnel
hey both work
mabel do you ever wish you could go back
and undo just one mistake nope i do
everything right all the time hey you
tool belt you ruined my life huh
that's amazing ah are you from the
future memory wipe this is a baby wipe
i'm a time traveler like a sonic
screwdriver you have like a time machine
or something that's kind of how it works
no could i borrow it
yes solve for your problems you know
this is sensitive extremely complicated
time equipment
it looks like a tape measure you shut
your time mouth
[Laughter]
oh you don't believe me
guess where i was
blendin blandin time anomaly removal
crew you're 270 12.
[Laughter]
i don't know if it's some kind of
paradox or if i'm just really tired poor
guy
one please oh sorry dude but you're
gonna have to take your belt off for the
ride one of your tools might fly off and
accidentally fix something
if only
[Applause]
like a
hawk our ticket to any moment in history
let's go get two dodos and force them to
make out no we got to be smart about
this save that population i don't miss
that baseball throw i won't hit wendy in
the eye and robbie won't comfort her and
they won't start going out see you later
see you earlier chuck yuck yuck
[Music]
[Music]
oh my
how far back did you go it's 12 o'clock
the dunk tank is now open
so far so good
do-over do-over
if and you can guess 15 pounds
i am a witch
time to round up a mob
yes whoa check it out i don't know if
it's a duck or a panda but i want one
one ball please you only get one chance
that's what you think
do not miss your chance to throw okay
dipper second chance don't mess this up
it's an absolute point it has to happen
so anyway we've been hanging out a lot
and i've been wondering if uh you wanted
to go out with me that happened a lot
faster yeah
oh no
he's going back again forces of time
naturally conspire to undo any new
outcomes third time's the charm
maybe don't play that game anymore
[Music]
ow my eye hey you all right maybe block
her face yeah you leave the fair
entirely
[Music]
uh wendy how badly do you want that
stuffed animal thing more than anything
of course
oh
god
it's so embarrassing
[Music]
it's like there's one variable missing
waddles and a one and a two and an
dude you missed did i
what the hell
[Music]
you're a stuffed creature of
indeterminate species miss
oh no so i was wondering if uh you uh
what dipper got for me
whatever can't even tell what species it
is
stupid
looks like i came to the fair with the
right guy
any time broseph what about watching my
pig
no
i knew it pacific a north [ __ ]
forever
[Music]
you didn't even want a pig before funnel
cake let's go get some dipper
[Music]
we messed up the timeline pacifica saw
the flyer and went waddles before i did
we just need to go back and do things
differently wait oh no fine wendy ends
up going out with rob no
don't golden i'll lose walls forever
oh
yep
yeah you done it far
when are we
the real question is when
you're waiting for that
do you hear that
is it real witch hunt
[Music]
be on the lookout for mountain lions
travelers
dysentery
where are we the 70s
absolutely
hey sister guess who gets to vote in the
future
ladies up top
teach it to your friends
give me that i'm gonna set the timeline
right
how do you go forward
that's a great question
that's coming
[Laughter]
but enough about me behold i was gonna
say are we going back through all the
episodes hey hey it's the previous
episode yeah
hey that's the first episode there was
the sea monster back there
[Music]
whoa
wow young grunkle stud
wait why does it smell so bad in here
oh yeah i've worked too hard to lose
this but what about waddles he was my
soul mate you said that about a ball of
yarn one
[Laughter]
and a one and a two and a huh
wow my eye
hey wendy are you okay
you know this is the perfect time for me
to oh god
thank you thank you thank you thank you
you two
how many rules you just broke
i'm asking i i wasn't there with you
blendon blandon
no
it was those kids and their leader
waddles that's a pig blender oh i'll get
you for this oh no
hey biceps yeah i'm talking to you
haircut
take your best shot
hello
from the future
it's good it's caramel i'm on it
[Music]
my hand oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
what are you looking at
all done
that
had some high-stakes drama if you ask me
that was a time crisis
that was delightful that was very
delightful love good time traveling
episode especially one of great
consequences
like abusing
an attractive red-headed woman
uh yeah that was fun they really
utilized that concept this is probably
one of my favorite ones in terms of uh
one that doesn't go down the horror
route and it does something that's just
purely sci-fi but still had me as
equally engaged throughout um and then
of course you know wrapping it up with
uh mabel you know like because because
in my mind i was watching this going
like you only wanted the pig like just
recently you know but then watching her
obsess over it and how much dipper
really does care about her like the
guilt trip apparently goes down this
path of oh no she really did love this
pig
so this pig better be around for the
future better be a serious regular
character because he had his chance he
had his shot
and that damn mabel and pig just uh
he could have been getting away he could
have been with wendy all summer man
they've been wendy all summer but it's
probably not going to happen no but it's
better in the long run yeah you know
drama high stakes you gotta root for him
character motives and goals
happening all around but yeah everything
they realized too and like the the
concept of time travel and i thought it
was like what they did with the past was
fun but i really want to see one that
stays into the future felt very rick and
morty-esque oh yeah and i'd love to deal
with that a little bit more but see how
it goes in terms of an episode though
yeah this was really fun it was really
fun and it got me like cringing a lot of
like ooh this is uncomfortable this
could really go wrong so yeah this is
about there's a blasty blast of an
episode yeah absolutely take it away
john love a little bit of time travel
shenanigans
and to you know when you get an excuse
to do a backdoor medley of like oh
here's moments we've been to before
here's earlier prior season bits uh i'm
always especially tickled by those and
yeah it was like at first the whole
thing with the pigs started out as like
oh it's a charming bit and it kind of
very smoothly worked into that where i
wasn't even anticipating like oh that's
got to be the cost because mabel's just
having the best day every time they go
back and for different to be happy she
has like some sacrifice needs to come
down the line i like them playing with
that jules verne sort of uh
idea of like yeah this is like a fixed
point like this is just gonna happen and
if you find a way like taking it one
step further too if you find a way
around it then there are going to be
even greater consequences or some other
equivalent exchange for that like yeah
it's nice because it's like
absolutely appropriately you know fun
and whimsical but also you know it's
actual sci-fi inspiration it's pretty
fun
and uh yeah always happy to get a justin
roiland appearance
adding to the rick and mortyness of all
these like playing a rick and morty
character pretty much yeah just crossing
over into this universe what that was
intentional
i'm curious i mean this
does this predate rick and morty i'm not
sure because i know like you know just
ron's been around in the animation game
for a while in sketch comedy but
i would be i would be fascinated to know
what kind of crossover there is there
yeah it's pretty much a rick and morty
ass character oh somebody had some
inspiration with the writing
yeah it seemed because yeah like all the
future stuff felt very sort of random
and mad cap in the way rick and morty
things are and i know he does a lot of
improv so even that name of like blendin
blendin
almost sounds or
20 70 like whatever year he makes up
with the nea over the seven like those
feel like like improvs he would have
dished out in the in the booth or
whatever yeah uh which i i always
applaud animation when they're working
with like like rick and morty for
example always kind of boggles my mind
because i'm like man it must be kind of
hard to work with so
such messy dialogue and so many uh like
improv takes or whatever because like so
much of what they do has to be improved
uh but yeah yeah i appreciated uh
his presence here and yeah as a story i
thought this one had a nice little
circle to it
yeah and i like when they can touch the
heart when it comes to the brother and
sister dynamic
this was fun it was a really fun when i
thought they knocked this one out of the
park and pacifica didn't win
it's all that matters hater [ __ ]
pacifica northwest yeah terrible woman
evil
no chance of redemption for pacifica no
hope that chicken pecks her eyes out
yeah
all right guys well thanks for being
here tell us in the comments where would
you like to time travel to the future
the past
what things you feel guilty about that
you wish you could redo over again
believe me i have a
very small list actually oh very very
small that's good that's a that's a way
to live maybe like one thing
huh
no no regrets no regret wow guys leave
your thoughts down below thank you so
much for being here we'll catch you guys
soon
[Music]